balala
je crois que tu peux y avait maintenant
parce que ça peut pas être mieux choisie
devrait rentrer chez toi pierre là c'est
un hommage énorme énorme depuis maurice
chevalier
j'ai pas vu ça franchement tu élimines
effet sur moi dans une mission sur
pierre palmade ce soir c'est une
spéciale à ces trois heures avec pierre
ce soir bien que pierre est d'ailleurs
ça va durer tellement longtemps
si je fais un petit avant silencieuse
parce qu'il est temps il est pas au lieu
ce ciel j'ai vraiment besoin d'être
confortable nous allons passer de trois
heures puis les deux c'est exceptionnel
mais là messieurs on va commencer donc à
la naissance pense qu'il faut prendre
les chats jouer 1
là on l'a bien pour trois heures mais
quel souvenir pierre de ma naissance
c'est très bien ça marche ça va bien ça
va bien vers la chemise pierrot super
comment jouer le bro non indiens bien
non et c'est là la cage leurs appareils
bon le look on a vu vous voulez rien
qu'hier sobre ce soir complètement sobre
un peu d'eau quand même même pas même
pas d'eau assez courageuse et bien bien
alors on a vu le look on a vu la boisson
la clean ça va il fait pas trop froid
ah ça va ça va bien aller plan des
invités alors une des raisons pour
lesquelles je vous ai invité ce soir
pierre palmade
c'est un spectacle qui s'appelle il joue
palmade au point virgule à 19 heures du
mercredi au samedi alors ces deux jeunes
comédiens de 23 et 21 ans qui s'appelle
cédric sizaire et brice hillairet qui
reprennent une dizaine de vos sketches
mise en scène par vous voilà c'est un
hommage exceptionnel qu'ils vont rendre
on peut le dire après ça peut faire un
peu prétentieux il joue pas le match que
je peux guitry non plus mais cesser sa
photo peut-être joué mais je crois que
j'étais pas très très bons comédiens
j'étais drôle j'écrivais mieux que je
jouais quand j'ai commencé je crois
hélas j'ai eu je crois je redécouvre
metex et il les joue bien effectivement
on découvre que c'est très bien écrit ah
oui moi je suis épatée par l'écriture
en tous les cas nous sommes obligés de
s'y mettre à deux pour faire un truc un
objet tout seul il n'imite pas il en
arrive à être immédiat et vous avez
obligé à se coiffer comme vous non je
veux qu'on pose la question j'ai froide
il aurait pu attendre que vous soyez
mort pour jouer vos sketches quand même
non vous voulez qu'on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble vraiment ça j'y tiens alors
regardez votre caméra c'est le diable
rouge vous vite magnéto serge original
m'a dit eto'o cherche à lui